alors maintenant comme vous êtes une
femme politique comme vous dites vous y
casser la vérité vous n'êtes pas
tellement langue de bois
1 il est assez franche du collier de
perles comme disait un journaliste on va
vous faire une interview mensonge on ne
bouge pas
bien alors l'interview mensonge c'est
facile il suffit de répondre sans dire
la vérité
entraînez vous alors vous mentir
mangement est ce que vous gagnez bien
votre vie oui je gagne bien ma vie je
gagnais très bien ma vie je la gagne
super bien je gagne plus que les
fonctionnaires de la ville de paris a
mis d'accord avec votre mari guy de
panafieu est-ce que vous avez un compte
commun vous mettez tout l'argent sur le
même compte où chacun à son compte la
maison ou oui bien sûr nous avons un
tournus commun nous avons un compte
commun et alors nous on chambre à part
est-ce que vous avez déjà frauder le
fisc
oui j'ai beaucoup frauder le fisc je
comptais vous demandez des tuyaux là
juste en sortant de l'émission
françoise de panafieu est-ce que vous
avez déjà couché pour du boulot on va
c'est à dire que là comme on ne prête
qu'aux riches mille fois c'est à dire
que je fasse ma vie et je me demande
d'ailleurs comment je suis encore là
bien bien très bonne a qu'un immense ont
alors je continuerai ce que vous avez
déjà trompé dit je vous interdis tout à
l'heure on va me dire que vous avez dit
vous avez dit non attendez j'ai dit non
mais attendez c'était interview ensemble
y avait qu à la maison mon fiancé n'est
pas la surprise de ce soir donc il n'est
pas la division
vous l'avez trempé j'ai trouv pegi oui
bien sûr or la rampe et bien vous n'êtes
pas ou là un pétard sgh alors bien alors
dernière chose les formidables dernière
chose on va allumer la lumière d'abord
non la dernière fois qu'on s'est vus
mais vous connaissiez pas bien la taxe
tobin vous avez j'ai approfondi
d'accord mais un petit cours avec madame
arlette laguiller allez bon vous êtes
vous êtes pour la taxe tobin
je vais te dire je vais vous dire pardon
la taxe tobin c'est une façon ça vous
inquiète
aristophane cela vous intéressera la
taxe tobin c'est une façon de faire la
révolution sont coupés de tête et sans
faire couler de sang et son boule hague
il suffirait que chaque sur chaque
transaction financière dans le monde on
prenne 0 1% ou 0 5% et sa dégagerait
chaque année 228 milliards de dollars et
ça permettrait d'éradiquer la pauvreté
c'est la révolution sans s'en mord son
goût l'accent quant à monsieur tobin qui
est pas un hippie c'est un prix nobel
d'économie américain prix nobel
d'économie qui un jour a mis ça au point
mais le sevrer nzi paul tout le monde
soit d'accord
le monde entier alors la france pourrait
commencer bien sûr mais faut que le
monde entier soit d'accord donc si ça
vous intéresse vous pouvez appeler
attaque dans le numéro s'écrit sur
l'écran je milite pour ça moi c'est une
grande cause pour laquelle j'ai envie de
militer en plus le vulgaire s'était pris
par biggar
bien merci françoise de panafieu jacquet